the biggest part of my job as a director
particularly if you're a writer director
is you give that character to that
person when they are cast you give them
the little candle that's that person's
soul and you say now it's yours I don't
know more than you you're the keeper of
that person I'm involved but I know I
don't hold the key to the character and
I almost have a very literal
conversations with my actors about that
because like you're saying if it's
personal and if you wrote it and you're
directing it there's a tendency I think
for actors to feel like they don't want
to take over too much or they're worried
that you'll keep interfering
and so I very much say it belongs to
them and I think you know in so many
ways filmmaking is a collaborative art
it's about giving it to each person and
saying you are the Storyteller and I
feel like they need to
feel that that's their corner of the
film they're responsible for